cientos de reservistas y veteranos del
ejército de Israel se movilizan hoy
frente a la Corte Suprema israelí en
rechazo al planes de reformas judicial
del gobierno de Benjamín netaniacu es
una protesta de tres días una marcha que
comenzó en el norte de Israel y que
llega hoy frente al tribunal supremo
para protestar contra lo que consideran
es una reforma que va a minar la
institucionalidad de Israel y sabe que
es uno de los participantes en la
manifestación Gracias Isaac por estar
con nosotros y cuéntenos por qué se
opone a esta reforma judicial porque
este no es una reforma es una es una
Revolución y nosotros estamos de acuerdo
que exista un país democrático un país
que hace 75 años es democrático y no
queremos perder la democracia porque la
democracia es lo más importante que
tiene este país No queremos ser Hungría
no queremos ser no queremos ser Polonia
queremos ser un país democrático que
defiende a las minorías también y lo que
ellos quieren hacer
no está bien muchas gracias
la palabra democracia es la que más
repiten los manifestantes porque temen
que esta reforma judicial limite El
Poder y la independencia de de poderes
entre el poder judicial y el gobierno el
poder gobernante y entre otras cosas le
permita al poder gobernarte influir en
la elección de los jueces ese será uno
de los primeros puntos de esta reforma
que será sometida a una primera votación
en comisiones el próximo lunes de ahí
que se haya convocado para esas jornada
una nueva jornada de movilización y de
huelga el próximo lunes y una
movilización frente a la que en ese del
parlamento israelí